The world is using the equivalent of one and a half planets...
...to support life on Earth.
Earth Hour was born out of a hope that this could change.
People are turning out their lights...
...to signal their concern about the future of our life on this Earth.
Introducing "I Will If You Will":...
...taking the passion of Earth Hour beyond the hour.
If 5,000 people agree to take public transportation instead of their cars for one week,...
...we'll climb 96 stories of this building.
I will conduct a free yoga class...
...if 500 people upload their own "I Will If You Will" challenge.
I will be dyeing this beard green if 10,000 people commit to supporting Earth Hour.
It's the one thing that we all share is the place that we live.
It's kind of common sense to look after it.
Together, we can find the energy to turn the inspiration of one hour...
...into the actions of every hour.